[Aplausos]
desde sempre eu acreditei que o mundo é
muito grande pra gente ficar num lugar
só e minha mãe me conta que lá pelos
meus 56 anos de vez em quando me
estressava pegava minha mochila e falava
vou embora
e é pra linha do trem e ficava lá
minha mãe ficava espiando pela janela
até a hora que ela fosse lá me pegar eu
voltava contrariada pisando duro porque
a linha do treino tinha me levado nenhum
lugar
eu comecei a trabalhar cedo e depois de
25 anos no mundo corporativo eu decidi
que ia mudar minha vida água na hora e
dessa vez antes de assumir um novo
desafio profissional eu resolvi pegar
minha mochila linha mais um pouquinho do
que a minha mochila linha e para os
estados unidos se quer um tempo e foi lá
que tive a idéia de fazer de começar uma
série de entrevistas com a comunidade
negra local mas ela só pra mostrar pra
todo mundo que todo mundo pode ir onde
quiser que você pode falar tudo que você
quiser
não existem fronteiras e fui depois dos
estados unidos foi até à europa quando
entrevistas depois recentemente a áfrica
do sul e eu notei que você pensar como
as comunidades negras é de onde eu
passei estavam similares para ruim tá
bom mas o que mexeu comigo que me fez
ficar mais pensativa e curiosa foi
perceber como a áfrica invadiu o mundo e
além de dominá lo com a presença e com
diversidade tem história suficiente para
liderar a construção de uma sociedade
melhor e aí comecei a pensar nesse
negócio
quando eu olhei para a diáspora africana
e é a migração massiva dos escravos
africanos escravizados
eu olhei e vi um movimento de
globalização porque eu tenho uma mania é
uma técnica de sobrevivência e de ficar
procurando onde ninguém vê saída eu fico
procurando uma saidinha e foi o que eu
fiz ali eu olhei para a diáspora
africana e falei ali tem um movimento de
globalização e
não estou aqui dizendo que a escravidão
foi boa o que eu estou dizendo aqui é
que os meus ancestrais
você sai de vocês fizeram da pior forma
possível o que ninguém fez e nós
permanecemos o que eles mostraram da nós
é que nós somos dominantes e não
excessivos
pois bem foram mais de 15 milhões de
negros sequestrados na áfrica levados
pra das américas e para a europa e
nenhum negro chegou brasil no seu
destino e ninguém pára para pensar nisso
junto com essas pessoas foram
transportadas as suas culturas a sua
mania de comer a sua forma de vestir a
uns idiomas as religiões e em cada lugar
onde a diáspora chegou houve uma
transformação sócio cultural que também
permanece
quando eu observo os 54 países do
continente africano com cheios de
sabedoria ancestral esses países são
mais ancestral não é primitivo
essa sabedoria são capazes de ler a
nossa sociedade a sociedade atual onde a
gente vive falando termos como é
compartilhar e sustentável e
colaborativo em nem saber que dentro das
culturas africanas dentro da tal
cosmovisão africana isso é natural
isso é original pois bem
por exemplo a palavra o mundo
o bom tom é o termo que designa é uma
filosofia na verdade que diz que nós
existimos uns através dos outros
reitera a humanidade ea importância dos
relacionamentos
se não tivessem sido decido educados com
esse pensamento bem provavelmente não
estaríamos enfrentando problemas com
xenofobia racismo misoginia classismo
violência policial em todos os lugares
mas depois eu comecei a pensar falei
isso é bem complexo vou procurar uma
coisa mais simples
eu lembrei de todas as vezes que fui a
nutricionista ela me disse assim foi já
foi a nutricionista é ela disse assim
marca só que é o seu prato tem que ser
super colorido para você ser saudável
aí eu olhava pra cada nota bom dura e
falava meu deus eu tô trabalhando mais
de oito horas por dia leva duas horas
para ir de serviço duas na volta pra
casa que horas que eu vou olhar a cor da
comida e aí eu conhecia comida tilp e eu
entendi mais uma vez que não existe um
novo sem o velho e que modelo de
nutrição milenar e atendia mega bem
fiquei pensando e observando essa comida
ele dá uma fome na verdade gente mesmo
fica concentrada até o morro morro de
fome eu adoro essa comida melhor comida
do mundo e aí o que é melhor da comida
etíope é o seguinte é uma comida que foi
feita pra compartilhar para comer com os
amigos com a família todo mundo junto
com a mão nesse quadro a tão e põe na
boca e foi na boca do vinho isso reitera
os relacionamentos e reitero cuidado e o
amor e quanto a família a gente está
vendo cada um comendo em frente à tv no
seu horário lá no seu cômodo tal
inteligente essa comida né comida da mãe
áfrica e oque vai continuar pensando e
assim como alimentação
a internet também tem a herança afro com
o acesso massivo à internet
foi necessário que se inventasse se
criasse uma forma é de comunicação que
lhes barrassem nenhum idioma
ok o uso dos ícones cresceu e hoje todo
mundo sabe né cada ícone que significa
no entanto esses ícones muito menos
complexos remetem à idéia dos símbolos a
dentre elas já existiam aí na costa
oeste da áfrica
togo costa do marfim gana e tem um
significado e tem vários significados
bem complexos por exemplo é esse é o
símbolo da democracia e unidade
o que diz o que é que os crocodilos
siameses estão interligados pelo
estômago ou seja dividindo a mesma
comida é isso quer dizer para nós seres
humanos que nós estamos interligados
pela mesma essência e qualquer
tribalismo qualquer guerra não são boas
para nós
só que em seguida ele sabe nesse negócio
está ficando cada vez mais interessante
e aí quando a gente viaja a gente vê nas
ruas de vários lugares muitos africanos
como estamos vendo agora aqui em são
paulo as coisas são paulo estão repletas
de nossos irmãos todos muito
empreendedores extremamente
empreendedores me impressiona como faça
chuva faça sol eles estão lá vendendo os
produtos dele e às vezes nem falam
português ea gente falar há como isso
acontece
o que acontece é que na áfrica
comunicação linguagem tange a pontos de
vista e é muito tradicional dos
africanos falarem sobre mais de um ponto
de vista ou seja quando você vai num
país como a áfrica do sul que tem 11
idiomas oficiais é você encontra pessoas
que falam no mínimo quatro outras falam
69 isso a prática da diversidade ali ó
como estilo de vida
são onze idiomas ok seguir e comecei a
entender como o mundo dá cada vez mais
se encaixando ali como um quebra-cabeça
é é muito plural e isso é muito à áfrica
isso então é assim nós consultarmos
freqüentemente enciclopédia da manhã a
áfrica
vamos encontrar muitas respostas para os
nossos problemas das nossas angústias
muitas vezes e assim a diáspora africana
provou que um povo ou vários povos
abertos ao pluralismo estão altamente
capacitados a continuar existindo pela
força da sua identidade e trouxe para a
sociedade muito antes de que qualquer
conversa sobre economia mundial
ao sobre diversidade a idéia de que é
possível ser diverso e pertencer a todos
os lugares sem perder a sua essência ea
gente está vendo agora as novas de aço
para onde as coisas acontecendo as
guerras as imigrações os refugiados
para mim fica muito nítido o que muita
gente ainda sangra pela áfrica espalhada
brutalmente pelo mundo
o sofrimento ainda é grande mas são
essas dores são exatamente essas dores
que nos dão um guia de como não deixar
acontecer novamente é hora de reagirmos
ou vamos permitir que se crie outra
massa de seres humanos dilacerados
vamos permitir que sentiu em outras
culturas
dessa vez a gente já sabe o que deu
errado
vale a pena nós temos curiosos estarmos
abertos respirarmos outros elementos
sendo mais acolhedores e é a energia de
cada cultura que vai produzir uma ponte
para a liberdade na diversidade não tem
certo e errado ea áfrica
ray a áfrica a áfrica despejo em todos
nós a sua realeza quando através do que
aprendemos com a sua história nos dita
um novo rumo para uma sociedade muito
mais igualitária muito mais próxima a
humanidade de cada um de nós uma
sociedade que vai além dos limites de
cor de idioma de localização uma
sociedade muito mais o ubuntu onde eu
existo através de todos vocês
obrigada
[Aplausos]